vous deviez pas l'embaucher on connaît
tous valérie damidot alors mais je vous
raconte inouïe à pascal a parlé oui
c'est vrai elle a dit elle a dit qu'elle
viendrait jamais douté alors je vais
raconter l'histoire il ya trois ans
valérie damidot on était en pourparlers
c'est vrai que j'ai pensé des médias 3
il ya trois ans en trois saisons
vraiment benjamin n'était même pas
encore là et j'en ai parlé à l'ancien
patron de ses huit chapelet ara aprikian
qui est maintenant le patron de tf1 et
il m'avait dit écoute si tu veux tu la
prends dans tpm pays je voulais qu'elle
fasse en plus un truc et il m'a dit en
revanche valérie damidot en plateau ça
ne marchera jamais je n'y crois pas du
tout au plateau donc si elle veut elle
veut bien qu'elle fasse de la déco en
plus sur ces 8 mai c'est que la déco
c'est dehors c'est à dire que je ne veux
pas dans un plateau sur un plateau je
trouve que c'est pas une animatrice de
plateau c'est ce qui m'a dit je vous
jure que c'est vrai et donc finalement
on avait abandonné le projet mais c'est
vrai que je voulais la faire venir il ya
trois ans j'avoue et c'était c'était
presque fait et y est
elle voulait un truc en plus c'est art a
pris quand le patron à l'époque a dit à
dinan voilà oui